welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and which X-Men universe is the MCU
using in the Marvels Deadpool 3 and
Secret Wars like what's going on right
now we got Beast played by Kelsey gramar
in the post credit scene of the Marvels
making him the third known member of the
X-Men from that fox Marvel era crossing
over into the MCU after Patrick Stewart
Charles Xavier and Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness and Hugh Jackman
confirmed to return as Wolverine in
Deadpool 3 but while the actors are
being pulled from that liveaction film
continuity the look of these X-Men are
definitely more vibrant and more
animated than we've seen them before so
are these the same Wolverine Professor X
and Beast probably not right but then
what version are they I recently asked
Kamala Khan herself Iman volani what she
thinks about this and I did a deep dive
into everything Kevin feige has hinted
about his plan for the mutants even
signs that he gave with past franchise
decisions to try to figure out which
X-Men Universe this actually is I'll
spoil the answer for you right now it's
going to be both the best X-Men universe
that we can imagine and a universe
doomed to die okay if we assume that the
universe of the Marvel post credit scene
with binary and Hank McCoy is the same
X-Men universe that Hugh Jackman
Wolverine is coming from in Deadpool 3
which I understand is a big assumption
but just assume that the post-credit
scene of one movie is kind of setting up
the events of the next movie coming out
I think there are four possibilities of
what Universe we could be seeing here
one the restored X-Men OG Universe this
would include the universe of the first
three X-Men films from the OTS plus 2014
states of Future Past as that movie
ended by restoring that original
timeline back to the original lineup
including Patrick Stewart Charles Xavier
James mors and cyclops C Berry storm and
Kelsey Grammar Beast second option the
X-Men 97 Universe since the '90s fox
X-Men animated series is being brought
back to Disney plus as X-Men 97 picking
up right where that series left off this
universe could be a liveaction
adaptation of the continuity of that
series which would really Elevate the
importance of that upcoming animated
title third option the X-Men first Class
Universe because the X-Men movies made
by Fox did split into two different
timelines of characters so this third
option would be the alter timeline
following the events of first class and
then Days of Future Past X-Men
apocalypse and dark Phoenix which would
include James maoy Charles Xavier
Michael fastfender Magneto Tai Sheridan
Cyclops even Evan Peters Quicksilver now
I got to say despite Evan Peter showing
up in W Vision I doubt that the MCU is
using that Universe mostly because
Nicholas Holtz was just cast as Lex
Luther in Superman Legacy and he plays
Beast Hank McCoy in this continuity
which leaves us our fourth option of
what Universe it is a new X-Men Universe
which would be just a new universe that
combines elements of all of the above so
let's look at the evidence so far Marvel
has only brought back film actors who
played these characters in the original
film continuity so Patrick Stewart Hugh
Jackman and Kelsey gramar which is
really weird for Kelsey gramar because
grammar wasn't really synonymous with
X-Men the way that Hal Barry or James
marsten were grammar was really just in
the Lesser beloved third film Brett
ratner's X-Men the Last Stand and then
he made a quick Cameo at the very end of
days of future past Kelsey Grammar is
also known around Hollywood as you know
not exactly a kind of guy who will spend
eight hours a day on set wearing the map
suit that Mark Ruffalo and Josh Brolin
and Tatiana masani were down to wear so
the fact that they went to this effort
to bring back Kelsey Grammar shows us
that this studio is for now committed to
a specific pool of talent that includes
Patrick Stewart Hugh Jackman James
Marsen Hal Barry Anna pacin FY Jensen
Ian McKellen and Rebecca Roma maybe also
Shan Ashmore and Elliot page and this
would make sense because that 2000 X-Men
film was how Kevin feige got his start
as an associate producer reporting to
Lauren Schuler Doner and a self-made
comic book Guru who snuck Hugh Jackman
into his office to read comic books
after director Brian Singer B them from
the set the Marvel's post credit scene
samples two different X-Men scores from
Days of Future Past and from X2 X-Men
United and in Multiverse of Madness
Charles Xavier quotes his line from Days
of Future Past just because someone
Falls and loses their way doesn't mean
they're lost forever suggesting a
connection to that continuity at least
in the way that all Peter Parker
variants instinctively knew the words
with great power comes great
responsibility and for what it's worth
when I asked Iman valani about this she
agreed admitting that she hasn't been
looped in on the Studio's mutant plans
what X-Men Universe do you think they
are in here like what Universe does this
take place in the the first three films
I guess yeah right like Kelsey gramar
that only makes sense um I mean they did
have is it 838 they did have like old
Charles Xavier in that one but he didn't
have his like yellow wheelchair in the
films right so it could be a different
universe but also maybe he just got the
wheelchair later I don't know uh any
X-Men universe is f that's not true I
was going to say any X-Men universe is f
with me but I still refuse to watch dark
Phoenix um Kelsey Grammar as the be is
just such a specific pull like they
could have pulled I know Patrick seart
back or Marsen back in but they're like
no no no we want you to think about they
flexing on us with that CG I was very
impressed when I saw the little teeth
uhhuh the yeah um which I it feels like
they use some of the technology that
they use on Ruffalo for Hulk you know
but they they did it specifically to get
like a comic accurate piece you know you
know just out of curiosity Beast
mentioned Charles Xavier who do you
think would be Charles in this reality
would be steuart or makoy Stuart seems
to make more sense Stuart I think Stuart
makes sense yeah given BEAST's age and
he's already in beasty mode you know I I
think Stuart so hopefully Ian McKellen
somewhere in there too right right and
then H ber pops up I think it' be a jump
scare if we get Anna pacin too but jump
scare and don't blame Iman for not
watching Dark Phoenix I know none of you
did either but fige also might be a bit
limited by other things when it comes to
declaring his MCU X-Men universe as the
same exact universe as those films in my
deep dive investigation on this mystery
I broke down how legal contracts with
Legacy producers might Force Marvel to
credit and pay people like Brian Singer
for any title that's too connected to
that film continuity which might even
include anything with X-Men specifically
in the title which is why an argument
could also be made for this liveaction
continuity being connected to something
that predated Brian Singer the X-Men 97
Universe because yes we've all seen how
Beast was redesigned with an appearance
closer to that of the Animated Series
the smaller head his underbite fangs he
wears no shirt only blue pants with a
yellow trim meanwhile Wolverine in
Deadpool 3 will be wearing a classic
blue and yellow suit which was very very
important to all the people involved
Charles in Multiverse of Madness dressed
as he did in the '90s Animated Series
Green Jacket blue stripe tie and he
floated in in the classic yellow hover
chair and while we were talking about
music the music the MCU has twice used
to announce mutants Charles and vers
Manis and Kamala Khan and M Marvel was
Ron W's theme from the 9s animated
series my favorite gifts I've ever
gotten are the things I use all the time
a water bottle I like or a comfy hoodie
I can wear when it's cold out if you're
looking for the perfect use it everyday
gift for somebody in your life give them
ridge ridge knows there are things you
got to carry with you all the time every
day and so those things got to be
comfortable to have in your pocket and
fit your Vibe that's why Ridge is
rolling out new hyperline wallets and
key cases plus a whole line of ceramic
powder wallets and soothing pastels rg's
hyper lime line is perfect perfect when
you want your gear to have that high
visibility easy to find Vibe you might
need if you're camping the ceramic
powder line is designed to be
fashionable and functional with color
options that look as good with your
outfit as they do in your pocket every
bridge wallet holds up to 12 cards plus
cash while remaining as Slim as possible
and are designed with RFID blocking
materials that protect you from digital
pickpockets the ridge key case hold up
to six keys with no jingling and you can
get 30% off your order when buying the
ridge wallet and key case together rid's
products have a 99-day risk-free trial
and are backed by a lifetime warranty
which is prob y Ridge has over 3 million
customers and more than 880,000 fivestar
reviews shop the holiday sale by going
to ridge.com rockstars and get up to 30%
through December 20th if you use my link
you can enter your email/ SMS for a free
chance to win a ridge bundle worth
$4,000 no purchase necessary when Ash
Crossen asked kige about his mutant
plans on the red carpet for the Marvels
he diverted to X-Men 97 but I know how
much you love the freaking X-Men is
there anything you can say about how
delicate that is to you and kind of what
the what the plan is why AR we going to
hear something I don't know if it's
delicate I it's super exciting but the
X-Men are as solid and Rich and great a
concept and characters as exist uh the
return to the Animated Series next year
which we're very excited about and I saw
some uh some new Final episodes today
which really bring you back to that to
that core of who the X-Men are and that
soap opera that those characters
represent and then in and then in live
action people will see perhaps soon ah
did you see it he shifted he said and
then in live action and he kind of sense
in that distinction in his mind between
animation and maybe what he might
consider to be the real thing not that I
agree with that way of looking at it but
that might just be his way of explaining
it to anybody watching fige clearly
values the themes of what the '90s xman
Animated Series represented but not
necessarily the exact logical continuity
and the fact that Kevin feige has used
film actors to voice the characters in
what if tells us that for him the voices
and the appearances of the actors is a
pretty important part of what he
considers to be canonicity and he's not
wrong General movie audiences who go
watch these things are always going to
first associate who is playing and
voicing these characters more than like
a a random Easter egg someone mentioned
in a scene that like you know 10% of us
caught I think we also have to look at
Kevin feige calling his live action MCU
616 that is very telling because it
shows us that he considers his films and
shows to be an adaptation of the 616
Universe from the comics which is a
different medium in his eyes he is
pulling from those Comics the most
cinematic elements and making a
liveaction version of them I don't know
if he considers the comics to be as
equally weightbearing as the films this
is to contrast the way Lucas film
approaches all of their media every
episode of bad batch is as Canon bearing
as a liveaction Star Wars film or as a
printed comic at least it's the case
since Disney bought Lucas film and it's
been kind of a frustrating thing for a
lot of comics writers over at Marvel
Kevin feige doesn't want this he doesn't
want to have to be beholden to
continuity's other storytellers set he
wants more control and we see this when
we watch the movie we think he's going
to adapt a comic word for word but he
ends up using it as just kind of like an
inspiration to build his own version of
reality that's what we saw with the
Illuminati in Multiverse of Madness it
seemed like the Illuminati but it ended
up doing its own thing which is why I
think we are really looking at a fourth
option of what X-Men Universe we're
looking at a new X-Men Universe in which
Marvel Studios is going to pull elements
from all Past X-Men continuities the
Beloved cast members from the original
films the vibrant costumes and the soap
opera vibes from the animated series and
yes Iman maybe even the way dark Phoenix
began to move away from the X-Men
moniker toward mutants and they're going
to build an entirely new X-Men reality
out of that that the studio can control
fully but I don't think that's what
X-Men are always going to be in the MCU
this plan at least in the Multiverse
Saga starting with Deadpool 3 is just a
temporary task force so we're looking at
the difference between two different
things an X-Men task force and a mutant
Academy or a mutant Community by casting
all these past era X-Men this is not a
universe that Marvel is building for the
distant future Patrick Stewart is 83
Hugh Jackman is 55 Kelsey gramar is 68
this is a temporary AR transition
universe that's being built for one
event Avengers Secret Wars this is a
short-term task force headed for a
one-time epic reunion and it's going to
be awesome but it's not going to last
this isn't going to be the mutant
community that we hang out with for 10
years after that director Sean levia has
said that Deadpool 3 will not reccon
Wolverine's death and Logan and I think
that the only way that they can do that
without confusing everyone is by
constructing a new separate Universe
filled with X-Men played by most of the
same actors we know these characters to
be but wearing the colors that Kevin
feige always felt the X-Men deserve to
have it's kind of like the X-Men dream
Universe it's going to have all the
2000's era excesses and ego Wolverines
brutality but also mixed with like
storms theatrical Bellow monologues it's
going to be the kind of universe that we
both love but we're also going to be
okay to see like Deadpool take a
wrecking ball to it even down to
fighting Wolverine on the ruins of a
20th Century Fox logo because this
temporary transition X-Men Universe must
end these Legacy stars do not want to
populate a new fertile community of
mutants to play out all that soap opera
drama that Kevin feige identifi but we
need that we need the slow burning
interpersonal conflicts the rivalries
the romances the Mysteries the
friendships the comings of age we need a
mutant Academy and for that you need a
new Logan you need a new Charles you
need a new Hank McCoy and you need to
say goodbye to any Universe where those
characters exist as other actors but you
also need the best goodbye possible
that's what secret Wars is so whatever
this new universe is that's being built
in the marveles in Deadpool 3 I think
it's going to end up being dissolved by
an incursion by Deadpool maybe Bert
maybe merged into battle world and then
those characters will go home just as
Toby McGuire and Andrew Garfield did the
door will be closed and the multi for
Saga will come to an end and then fige
will build a new Mutant Saga around the
younger mutants like Kamala Khan so in
total we will have the infinity Saga
we're in the Multiverse Saga and we'll
get the mutant Saga now in 2024 new
rockstars is actually going to embark on
a weekly breakdown series of all X-men
movies so please subscribe to this
channel subscribe to all three channels
in our Network follow me on all socials
at eaos thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time
bye
[Music]